we're asked to rewrite the expression 7
times open parentheses 5 plus 11 close
parentheses as the sum of 35 and another
whole number so really what they're
asking us to do is just apply the
distributive property we have 7 times
the quantity 5 plus 11. now this is easy
to calculate you could just say 5 plus
11 is 16 and then 16 times 7 is what
that's 70 plus 42 which would be 112.
but that's not what they're asking us to
do they're not saying just calculate
this they're saying express this as a
sum of 35 and another whole number so
let's apply the distributive property
and let's see if we can get a sum of 35
and another whole number so 7 times 5
plus 11 that's the same thing as seven
times
five
plus
seven times
eleven and you can see with this
expression editor right over here it
tells you it puts it kind of the nice
math formatting for what it looks like
for the computer so for distributing the
7 over the 5 and the 11 it's 7 times 5
plus 7 times 11. well 7 times 5 is 35
and 7 times 11 is 77. now have we done
what they're asking us they said rewrite
this expression as the sum of 35 and
another whole number well we've done
that we've written it as a sum of 35 and
another whole number and we were able to
do it do it using the distributive
property so let's check to make sure
that we got the right answer yes we did
let's do one more of these
rewrite the expression 12 plus 75 in the
following form
a times 4 plus c
where a and c
represent whole numbers
now that this might look complex but
they're really asking us to factor out
an a factoring out an a out of this
expression right over here seeing how
much we can factor out so that one of
these two numbers becomes a 12 becomes a
four so let's think about how to do that
if we look at these two numbers the
greatest common divisor of 12 and 75
looks like it is three three is
definitely divisible in two or both of
them are divisible by three so you can
write twelve twelve is the same thing as
three times four
and seventy-five is the same thing as
three times
three times 25.
now what we could do is we can
essentially factor out we can factor out
the 3. so this is or you could say we're
undistributing the 3. so that's the same
thing 3 times 4 plus 3 times 25 that's
the same thing as 3
that's the same thing as 3 times
4 plus 25
3 times 4
plus 25
and it looks like we've actually put it
in the form that they want us to put it
in where 3 is a and 4 is right there
it's 4 and then c is 25 so we've put it
in the right form let's check our answer
we got it right